Brian my beautiful Blake sexiest man in
the world all those things and yeah she
is the sexiest man yeah
right there look at you
beautiful and happy yeah so annoying
no but to cheer us up when you started
kind of being interested in girls you
weren't as that cool or smooth with it
no no no not at all I don't believe it
no no I really I went through puberty at
like 27.
this is a freak thing yeah it's not good
yeah
the girl who's the girl in school the
first the first girl the first well I
was obsessed with this this girl uh uh
Fiona gorchinski
yeah
she said and she used to actually she
used to take the bus the the the
opposite way of my actual home and I
would get on the bus just to sit next to
her wow for 45 minutes the wrong way oh
there's something wonderful about it
there was something yeah
I love it when you're young it's so cute
when you're older it's just stalking
you're like on some kind of watch list
yeah yeah but I remember when I was I
couldn't have been more than I don't
know 11 years old and I and I I was just
about to get off the bus because enough
is enough I'm about to enter like
Seattle or something so I'm starting to
get off the bus and I decided to like
kind of hit her with like this cool look
or something like this like one of these
like real sort of Don Johnson Miami Vice
[Laughter]
but I I do this I do this move as I'm
getting down off the bus and I sort of
delay a little too long and the bus
doors closed on my backpack in my
backpack and the bus just starts to
leave
banging on the side of the bus driver
finally stops opens the door let's
release this my you know idiot bag
backpack and I could never look at her
again
that was terrible yeah well she's
looking at you now
can you imagine like he's the guy with
that backpack
he's the idiot with the Ren and Stimpy
backpack
before we do another thing yeah is there
a doctor in the house why yes there is
uh Dr Will Ferrell wow
since you were last here yes who made
you a doctor
um uh the University of Southern
California okay which is uh my
university in Los Angeles and I received
an honorary doctorate they say it's
honorary I think it's for real
I've performed 13 successful surgeries
uh and a hundred that didn't go so well
um uh so I'm currently I have a lot of
malpractice issues yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but at these things you have to
make the kind of the inspirational
speech so what did you tell the young
people I um yeah it I hadn't been put in
that position before because usually I
just make fun of things right and and
that's uh that's easy but then you have
to be Earnest and uh yeah that was that
was a difficult task uh so I I just told
them to uh keep your feet firmly planted
on the ground and reach for the stars
which I read on the back of a cereal box
speech took a very unexpected turn I
feel uh at the end yes yes no I I
thought I would Inspire the graduating
class by uh singing a Whitney Houston
song today
as well the theme from The Bodyguard yes
I will always love you yeah I will
always look lovely yes yeah and now
apparently you sang the whole thing
I started thinking do I just sing a
couple of lines or do I torture the
students and their parents by singing
the entire song
and I chose the latter yeah he's not
joking this is a tiny clip if you
actually can I just say you're rather
good oh thank you
and uh
[Music]
you get to wear the suit yeah which is a
nice you know kind of like I'm wearing a
suit yeah yeah well it's like a big red
body condom yeah sure whatever you want
but Josh like that it's really you that
like hey hey hey
yeah no nothing there's nothing that
can't there's no space in that thing at
all when I put it on I can actually
taste my own genitals
yeah did they roll you in town or
something uh I do that's just that's
just when I get home for my wife
good will you coach you coach I coach I
I've experienced the same thing you
forget he'd be the worst coach
why because it could be down 20. don't
worry guys you're doing really good
there are a lot of positive things
happening
it's okay you learn more from defense
have you ever said that out loud will
sadly that's exactly
but I did have a moment where I I was
screaming at my oldest son who was 10
years old at the time and I was like
Magnus
Madness Madness and he stops in the
middle game he's like what
and I realized I had lost my mind and I
said I just said never mind
try to get closer to the ball
but it's hard it's hard to not get
wrapped up in the excitement so it must
be hard because like everyone must
recognize you at a game uh usually
usually I was I was growing my mustache
out for Anchorman 2 and coaching on the
sideline and the opposing coach was like
you look familiar
uh and I go yeah
are you that actor I'm like I think so
he said is that mustache real
I said yes why would I be wearing a fake
monkey
it's happened honey hold on I gotta put
my fake
so that I'm unrecognizable why we don't
think of Canadians as having accents and
yet usually we do you've lost your
accent you would say yeah I sort of
trained myself out of it but you know I
go back home and it it pops up again
it's uh that's all out of work I hear
that's all Ottawa oh yeah
[Laughter]
but it's all about everything is I I
it's a bad word but I'm sorry so you
handle everything with oh [__] buddy
and is it something about the Canadian
accent that makes you a really bad liar
um yeah well yeah we're not we're not
good at lying or fighting really
good that's a Slappy it's not very sexy
why don't you go to the Border trying oh
yeah yeah I was I I my wife is a foodie
she we she loves these uh apple pies
that they make at this at this place in
Vancouver where I grew up so we grabbed
a bunch of them and headed we're driving
back down to the States and we were
across the border you're not a little
across the border with like yeah
and this guy knew something was going on
and we get up to the border crossing
yeah
most like a Hollywood actress they have
like a kilo of cocaine
my voice always gets really high when
I'm when I'm like lying he was like you
got anything any sort of fruit any
vegetables anything like that I was like
no
it's like vegetables
and he's basically he ages had me on the
hook and he looked at me and goes hey I
remember that you remember that movie
did that movie Just Friends and I was
like yeah yeah he was like you know that
song at the end of it where you sing
This I Swear by all for one and I was
like yeah he was like yeah go ahead
no basically he's saying dance monkey
but you dance
[Laughter]
[Music]